sometimes you know you have to kind of
move forward with you know the things
that you need to do and for 90 Day
Fiance star Eve that means divorce I
never felt like there was going to be
any issue ET can confirm he filed for
divorce from her husband Muhammad on
Thursday in New Mexico a filing that
shouldn't come as a surprise to fans
just two months after the couple first
revealed their split honestly I just
don't know what the future holds for us
the former couple who wed in January is
divorcing less than a year into their
marriage E.T spoke with Eve in June
during happier times Muhammad was just
so different than anybody that I ever
met like he literally like saw straight
through me like into my soul what do you
say to viewers who feel as if Muhammad
is manipulative
because there there are a lot of people
who think he is I would say kind of like
those blanket statements sometimes
aren't necessarily based in fact so you
know that can be a little frustrating to
me yeah but it wasn't long before Eve
started changing cartoon the pair broke
up in August amid a cheating scandal and
domestic violence charges I want to make
that right I texted this one I told her
I am a married man please talk text to
me anymore I know I did wrong all I can
do now is saying sorry to my wife once
filming the season wrapped the two
revealed during the 90-day tell-all Eve
caught Muhammad cheating I asked him if
I could see his phone and when that
happened I saw inappropriate things I
saw pictures and calls and put the
pieces together and allegedly text
messages with the woman suggest he was
only using Eve for a green card it's
very um
um shocking raw um disappointing
saddening she chose to spend his time
focused on
starting other relationships engaging
activity he a married man should not be
engaging in
I do a lot of Eve um she doesn't deserve
that then in August he was charged with
battery and assault by the Albuquerque
Police Department stemming from an
alleged altercation with Muhammad which
she denies Eve's reps are also denying
all allegations of abuse calling them
false and made up by Muhammad in an
effort to stay in the U.S and avoid
being deported
[Music]